Good morning everyone back back to Rome today,
back to Rome,
which was beginning to emerge as the worlds or the ancient world's greatest
super power and emergence that we're going to see had a profound impact on Roman
architecture.
And we'll also see that there were a number of men who affected,
uh,
this superstardom for Rome and they're men that I'm going to talk about and talk
about with you today.
These included Julius Caesar Pompey,
the Great Mark Antony and Octavian Augustus especially Octavian Augustus
Augustus,
first emperor of Rome.
And it's the reason that I've decided to call this lecture today from brick to
marble,
Augustus assembles Rome.
You see on the left hand side of the screen,
a portrait of Julius Caesar.
It's a green diabase portrait of Caesar.
It's now in Berlin.
And I believe actually that it is a portrait that was commissioned by Cleopatra
herself.
She commissioned it for a building that she and Cesar were putting up,
an Alexandria called the Kaiser.
He them that honored Cesar.
Uh,
and you can see that he is represented as he was.
It's a quite realistic portrait with the lines and wrinkles with his,
a receding hairline and so on,
uh,
accentuated in this portrait.
On the right hand side of the screen,
we see an image of Pompey,
the great,
uh,
a marble portrait that is now in the knee,
Carlsberg,
glip ditech in Copenhagen,
and a portrait that shows that Pompey the great,
very much wanted to ally himself with Alexander the great because if you look at
his very full head of hair,
you can see that he wears it in the center,
uh,
pushed up in a kind of pump a door,
which is a reference to the same kind of upsweep that was worn by Alexander the
Great,
I want to give you a few,
I want to give you a little bit of information about Caesar,
about his life,
about some of his accomplishments,
because these are going to have an impact on the architecture,
on our discussion of the architecture that he commissioned in Rome.
We know that Caesar was elected console in 59 BC.
He then joined with Pompey the great and with a man by the name of Crassus to
form.
What is known as the first triumvirate.
The,
the result of that first triumvirate was in part that Caesar received,
uh,
a console ship in Gaul.
Uh,
but despite all good intentions,
just a few years later,
in 54 BC,
the triumvirate fell apart.
Difficult Times,
uh,
where the case in Rome between 53 and 50 BC,
there were food shortages and riots in the city.
Uh,
and the Senate was very concerned that these uprisings would leave lead to a
takeover by the populous of the city.
Pompey took charge,
he took control of the Senate and he restored order.
And His reward for so doing is that the Senate was willing to work with him to
try to overthrow his rival.
That is Julius Caesar Crassus the other member of the triumph.
It had since died.
But Caesar got the upper hand at the end of the day.
And it was Cesar who defeated Pompey the great at a very famous battle,
the battle of far solace,
uh,
which took place in 48 BC after the battle of our solace and his defeat by
Julius Caesar,
Pompey fled to Egypt where he was murdered.
And in fact,
the Egyptian slit Pompey's head put it on a plate and presented it to Caesar.
Now you think Cesar would have been happy about that?
He wasn't because although he was thrilled to have defeated Pompey the great,
uh,
he did not,
he did not like seeing a,
the head of a fellow Roman delivered to him on a plate.
Uh,
Cesar at that point,
despite his victory,
what was foremost in his mind was his affair with Cleopatra and he stayed in
Egypt with Cleopatra for a period of time.
Uh,
but in 45 BC,
by 45 BC,
he had returned to Rome.
He was acclaimed dictator in that year in 45 and after that he pursued fiscal
reforms for Rome.
And also he commissioned a number of very important public works.
And that's where,
uh,
Roman architecture obviously comes into play despite the fact that he initiated
those reforms and built buildings and,
uh,
you know,
built up that the city and interesting ways,
uh,
the aristocrats and Rome considered Caesar retirement.
They considered him a tyrant because they felt that the influence of Cleopatra
had rubbed off too much on him.
And his ambitions were two much monarchical,
uh,
and the aristocrats,
encouraged,
uh,
his murder and he was assassinated.
As all of you know,
by Cassius and Brutus in the year 44 BC on the ides of March,
uh,
anti was divinized by the Senate.
He was made a god by the Senate in the year 42 BC in his biography of Julius
Caesar,
the,
uh,
the writer,
a Tony's bus who was a secretary and a biog refer to the emperor Hadrian and the
second century A.
Dot.
D.
So at Tony is wrote a biography of the 12 Caesars,
a very famous biography that many of you may know served as the basis for Robert
Graves,
a very well known I,
Claudius,
uh,
which also accentuates again the biographies of those first 12.
CAESARS.
And although Caesar himself was dictate or not emperor,
he is the first of the Caesars who is covered by sue at Tony's.
And in Sua,
Tony is his biography of Julius Caesar.
He tells us about some of these major architectural commissions that Caesar
embarked on in Rome.
And it's interesting to read about these because we'll see that all of them see,
seem to have been the best and the greatest.
And I think one of the explanations for this is the time that Caesar's spent in
Alexandria,
in Egypt with Cleopatra.
She wanted to show him the sites.
And in fact,
they went on a very famous barge trip together down the Nile in which she showed
him the pyramids.
And the Sphinx is a,
that we're there to be seen.
And he was extremely impressed by what he saw in Egypt and decided,
uh,
that one of the most important things that he could do that he could contribute
to posterity visa vi Rome,
was to make roam into a city that was the equal of Alexandria that had similar,
uh,
large scale buildings and impressive monuments the way Alexandria did.
So he came back to Rome,
he undertook this major building project and Sua Tony is,
tells us that he built,
he wanted to build,
he started to build a temple to Mars.
That,
so at Tony has described as as the biggest in the world,
why to compete with the buildings of Alexandria.
A vast,
not just a theater of vast theater,
a Greek and Latin public libraries.
We know of course that the greatest library in the war and the ancient world at
this particular time was the library at Alexandria.
So he wanted,
uh,
libraries in Rome that could compete with the Great Library of Alexandria.
And he was also particularly interested in engineering marvels.
He,
uh,
built or he began to build a highway from the Adriatic across the APP and nines
to the Tiber.
And then,
uh,
most famously a canal cut through the isthmus of Corinth that was in large part
achieved,
uh,
and one can still see that canal if one visits Corinth in Greece today.
So he had vast ambitions,
but many of these ambitions were cut short by his assassination in 44 BC.
He was not able to achieve architecturally all that he had hoped.
One building that he was able to complete or almost complete,
uh,
was a forum in Rome.
The forum,
you,
Liam Iul,
I,
U M,
which is after his family name,
you Ileus,
uh,
the form you will Liam or as we usually call it,
the forum of Julius Caesar in Rome.
A was a building that he was able to begin in the year 52 BC and then it was,
um,
it was inaugurated in 46 BC,
which is a couple of years before his assassination.
It wasn't quite finished at the time of its inauguration and it was left to
Caesar's follower,
Augustus first emperor of Rome to actually complete some of the details of the
form.
But for all intents and purposes,
it was done by 46.
I show you a Google earth of aerial view of,
uh,
the Roman forum as you see it here.
We've looked at this before,
the Roman forum,
the coliseum just for you to get your bearings,
the circus maximus,
the Palatine Hill,
the capital line hill,
the Victor Emmanuel monument,
tear muscle [inaudible] via day fori and periodically here the so called
imperial,
four of which Augustus's forum,
which we're also gonna talk about today,
is apart.
The Forum of Caesar is very close to the Roman forum.
It's located just to the left tier and above.
Uh,
the wedding cake of Victor Manual.
You'll see it here and you can barely make out the three columns that are still
preserved from the temple.
Uh,
that was located in side this forum.
So you can see it was adjacent to,
and in fact connected to the Roman forum that lay over here.
So a forum,
uh,
and in that forum,
a temple,
a temple to Venus,
Venus,
Ghana tricks,
I x,
Venus,
Ghana tricks who was the divine ancestors of the Julian family.
The Julian family traced its ancestry back to Venus via a niece through a nice,
uh,
so this was the very special patron goddess of not only Caesar himself,
but of the Julian family.
This is a plan of the forum of Julius Caesar as it would've looked a when the
building was inaugurated in 46 BC.
And I think you can see here that it has,
uh,
two major prototypes,
that,
that models that were being looked back at when this was designed,
uh,
beginning in 52.
Uh,
you can see that it is based heavily on earlier Roman forum,
Sam night slash Roman forum design as we saw it in the city of palm pay.
Think of the forum of Pompei.
Uh,
but it also was based in part on a building that we have not looked at in which
no longer survives but we have information about and that is that uh,
guys,
Maria Mercy's rhythm of Julius Caesar that he and Cleopatra put up in,
in Alexandria.
And we know enough about that building to know it too was an open rectangular
space with colonnades around it and a temple as part of it.
So this whole idea of temple in a rectangular complex,
we see it in Alexandria contemporaneously.
We see it earlier in Pompei at the forum of Pompei.
So a great open rectangular space open to the sky with colonnades on either
side.
You can see on this side there are some additional chambers and based on what
those look like and plan,
I am sure you can tell me what they are.
Does anyone know,
think back to what we saw in palm pay that looked similar to this.
What are these here?
What Stowe,
Stowe storage did you say?
Or Storage?
Uh,
not exactly.
Storage shops to bear and I remember the tobacco and I that we saw fronting the
houses in palm pay.
These are a series of shops or to bear night opening off the left,
a colonnade of the,
of the forum and then on the sh one of the short sides pushed up against the
back wall.
In fact,
in this case almost projecting out of the forum to a certain extent the temple
of Venus Ghana tricks we can see in plan and the dominates the space in front of
it just as the Capitol Liam did at palm pay.
Uh,
we can see the general plan conforms to early Roman temple architecture as we've
described it with its use of the trust can plan and the Greek elevation.
We can see that there is,
it has a,
well I'll show you this in a moment,
but take my word.
It has a high podium.
It has a deep porch,
it has freestanding columns in that porch.
It has a facade orientation,
although one idiosyncrasy of this particular,
uh,
temple is that the staircase,
is located not just on the front but on the two sides,
but only at the level of the podium.
The staircase is not encircled the building as it would have and a Greek temple,
uh,
but it goes beyond the front to the sides of the podium to allow access to it
that way as well.
A single entrance because this is a temple of Venus and not the cup and not the
capital on triad.
And then columns,
freestanding columns on either side,
uh,
and but a flat back wall,
a very much in the trust and manner.
So a temple that is very much in keeping with the other kind of temple
architecture that we have seen thus far.
What significant though,
again,
is that the choice of the choice of goddess to honor here,
the fact that it is Venus,
again,
a tricks,
a personal God is from the point of view of Julius Caesar's.
Someone who was,
uh,
who was,
associated closely with his family,
with the genesis of his family and not with the Roman state as a whole.
And that's a very important distinction.
The difference between putting up a temple to the Capitol on triad,
a very state oriented thing to do,
to putting up a temple to your own personal goddess.
It signals a certain change.
Uh,
visa vi the way these individuals thought about themselves and uh,
may,
may again have had something to do with the way Cesar was perceived in Rome and
to his eventual demise.
In fact,
I should also add that Caesar,
because his relationship with Cleopatra ended up putting up a statue of
Cleopatra as the Egyptian Goddess,
Isis in this temple as well,
standing right next to a venous Gannett tricks,
which was a pretty arrogant and probably a pretty stupid thing to do in
Republican Rome,
where,
uh,
where Cleopatra was considered very,
very interesting public figure because she did come with him to visit Rome at
one point,
uh,
but was a,
also a maligned by many among the aristocracy as an enemy of Rome.
I'm showing you here a view of the forum of Caesar as it looks today.
And you can see the columns on the left hand side from the colonnade.
Some of those still stand.
Uh,
you can see the staircase or the foundations of the staircase and the podium
tall podium again of the temple of Venus Ghana tricks.
But you can see that only a very small number three in fact of the columns are
preserved.
So it is an actually quite ruined his state.
Uh,
and what you're looking at here is actually not even for the most part,
the,
uh,
Julian a building because we know that this building was seriously damaged in a
fire later,
uh,
and that it was restored by the emperor demission and the late first century a d
and then by the emperor Trajan into the early second century Aad.
And so what stands today is primarily a later structure,
but we do believe it was based very closely on the original Julian building.
And in that regard is a very good reflection of what it would've looked like.
This coin over here shows the temple as it was in the time of Julius Caesar.
We see,
uh,
the altar in the front of the altar because the sacrifice always takes place in
front of a Roman temple.
The temple itself with its columns that are parted on this coin only to show the
statue of being a scan,
a tricks inside the cult statute,
uh,
the colonnades on either side.
And then if you look closely at the pediment,
you can see that there's sculpture in there and we have literary descriptions of
what that sculpture depicted.
And we know it was a scene of Venus rising from the sea.
So being as good at tricks rising from the sea,
the closest thing probably to it is something like for you,
for those of you who know it,
the Bata cellies primavera in Florence is probably the sort of the idea here for
emerging from the waters and in her depiction in this particular a pediment
above.
And we know that there were also scenes of cupids carrying the arms and armor
probably of Mars.
Uh,
this is me with a former graduate student of mine pointing out,
he wrote a dissertation on the Forum of Caesar,
which was afterwards published as a book.
Uh,
but he,
he's pointing out to me,
here are some of the,
uh,
some of the architectural detail that still survives at one can see when one
wanders through that forum today.
And,
uh,
you can see the very deep drill work here,
deep drill work that is actually not characteristic of the time of Julius
Caesar,
but rather of the time of demission and Trajan.
So probably this decoration belongs to the later renovation of this particular
structure.
This gives you perhaps the best idea of what the temple would have looked like
in the forum.
Uh,
a restored view of the temple of Venus Ghana tricks in the forum of Julius
Caesar with it.
It's an inscription telling us that Caesar,
a dictator of Rome,
uh,
put it up,
fake it.
Uh,
as you can see here,
you can see the tall podium,
you can see the facade orientation,
although again,
there was a staircase on the three sides of that podium.
Uh,
you can see the birth of Venus in the pediment above.
You can see the columns over here of the side of the colonnade,
of one of the left side of the forum that would've had statues on bases,
the shop's behind.
Uh,
and most importantly,
what this restored view shows you is the relationship between the temple of
Venus,
Ghana tricks and Caesar's forum.
And the Capitol Liam on the top of the Capitoline hill,
because when you take away the victor of monument of the Victor Emmanuel
Monument,
which is there now in which we saw in the earlier image,
you can see that the building that was up on top of the hill at this particular
time was of course the capital and the temple of Jupiter Omc.
And I mentioned to you at the time we talked about the temple of Jupiter Omc,
although the a Daleo as redesigned by Michelangelo with the Senatorial Palace in
the back,
which is where the temple of Jupiter Omc was,
faces modern Rome,
the ancient temple faced ancient Rome faced the Roman forum.
Uh,
and so you see it facing the Roman forum in this restored view.
So I don't think it was coincidental.
The Romans were very careful as we've learned about how they cited their
buildings and they like to make references from one building to another.
I don't think it is any coincidence that she sees her chose this site for his
temple of Venus so that anyone who gaze that it would also see out of the corner
of their eye,
the Temple of the Capitol on triad on the Capitoline hill and that would only
enhance Caesar's stature in the eyes of his contemporaries.
Uh,
you see now portraits of Marc Antony on the right hand side of the screen of
black basalt,
portrait of Antony now in England,
and a portrait of Rome's first Emperor Octavian Augustus on the lefthand side of
the screen,
a fantastic bronze image of him that was part of an equestrian statue found in
the North Sea near Greece.
With regard to Antony and Octavian after Caesar's assassination in 44 BC,
it was Marc Antony who rose to power.
Octavian was only 19 at the time,
so your age.
Uh,
and he was the grand nephew of Caesar,
so he had a familial relationship,
although a fairly distant one,
two a of the grand nephew of Caesar.
And this 19 year old upstart tried to overthrow Marc Antony and he was not
successful in the why's.
If you can't beat them,
join them.
Way of thinking about life and the world,
uh,
Octavian joined with Antony,
with Mark Antony and a man by the name of Lapidus to form what we know of as the
second triumvirate.
And that happened in the year 43 BC.
Once they had formed the,
uh,
the second triumvirate together,
Octavian Antony took all of their military forces and each of them had a
considerable amount and they combine them with the objective of going after
Cassius and Brutus casters and Brutus Julio Remember,
had murdered,
uh,
Caesar and they were successful at so doing.
They con they beat,
they beat and murdered,
uh,
Cassius and Brutus at the battle of Philippi in the year 42 BC,
a very important battle.
The Battle of Philippi in 42,
B c Mark Antony,
who not only,
um,
uh,
rose to power after Caesar's assassination,
but rose in the life and times of Cleopatra they had entered into,
well,
there's some rumors that this happened or began much earlier in time,
but at any rate,
Mark Antony,
uh,
takes up with Cleopatra and he joins her and in Egypt and he spends a good deal
of his time in the eastern part of the empire with his power more Octavian very
smartly realized Antony is distracted.
This is a perfect time for me to try once again to gain the supreme power that I
want.
I don't want to be part of a threesome.
I want a rule Rome completely myself.
Uh,
and uh,
he defeats Antony and Cleopatra.
I one of the most famous battles of all time,
the battle of Actium,
a naval battle,
which took place off the Northwestern coast of,
of Greece in 31 BC after that very famous battle.
Antony and Cleopatra commit suicide and Octavian becomes the sole emperor of
this new emerging superpower.
Uh,
and he is appointed as Augustus,
which meant that he had a special kind of majesty in the year 27 BC.
We have additional information about Augustus from sewer.
Tony is his biography of him.
Uh,
he wrote one of him obviously as well,
and from Augustus,
his own account of his life and of his accomplishments.
I mentioned that Octavian and that's called the rays guest di Di we out gousty.
Uh,
I mentioned that and took the title of Augustus in 27 BC and he was emperor of
Rome for a very long time from,
uh,
the,
from that year 27 until his death in Aad 14 at the age of 76,
which was a very ripe old age to live to a,
at a time when most people were women were dying in childbirth.
That 10 to 20.
And,
uh,
men,
we're dying for the most part in their 30.
So 76 was a very old age,
indeed in ancient times,
and it meant that Augustus was emperor of Rome for a very long period.
Uh,
as you can see now at his death,
uh,
Augustus deposited three documents besides his will,
with the vestal virgins in Rome.
And these included instructions for his funeral,
a kind of state of the Union address,
what was the situation in Rome and in the empire at the time of his death or
right before his death.
And then most importantly for us,
a resume of his act,
a resume of all of his accomplishments during his lifetime,
which were meant to be carved on two bronze plaques that were to be set up in
front of his tomb in Rome.
These are the famous res guests,
di Di we,
owl gousty.
Uh,
and that means the list of things accomplished of the divine Augustus because
Augustus like Cesar before him was made a god was transformed into a god at his
death.
Uh,
and this lists all of his accomplishments at home and abroad,
the battles that he won,
the cities that he formed.
A,
but most important for us,
it lists dozens and dozens of building projects.
For example,
at lists 82 temples that he either restored or built in Rome,
in Rome itself.
Uh,
so it gives you some sense of the magnitude of this man's a building objectives,
uh,
and uh,
and,
uh,
and it's very important to us as a compendium of what he does.
Some of these buildings still survived,
some of them don't.
But this is a very informative list indeed.
And it shows us that to Augustus as to Cesar before him,
the building of buildings,
uh,
was extremely important to making a building's not only to remake Rome,
and they,
uh,
you know,
as a great city of the ancient world,
uh,
but also to leave something for posterity.
Uh,
and of course,
both of them were successful in both of those objectives.
Very important for us.
Today is also the words of Seward.
Tonia Sua.
Tony tells us that Augustus bragged that he and I quote,
found Rome,
a city of brick and left Rome,
uh,
city of marble,
a city,
a brick,
meaning that brick tile that we saw in palm pay.
He found a Rome that was built out of that same kind of brick tile that we saw
palm,
but he wanted to transform.
He left the city of Rome,
uh,
a city of marble.
And that's exactly the major thrust of today's lecture.
Augustus builds Rome Augustus build Rome as a marble city in the model of
ancient Greece in the model of Athens,
in the Greek part of the world.
It's a rhetorical exaggeration,
but we're going to see from the to Augusta buildings that I show you today that
it wasn't far off the mark,
that he really did create a city of marble on the Tiber.
Uh,
and he left for posterity.
That Greek marble temple,
a hellenized Greek marble city,
a hellenized,
a city that builds on the Hellenization of Roman architecture that we've already
talked about.
What made a Augustus is boast possible was the fact for the first time in its
history,
uh,
a high quality marble was available to Rome,
in close proximity that is marble from Italy itself as opposed to imported
marbles.
We've seen up to this point that the Romans wanted to build marble buildings
that they,
that they created a full marble walls,
the first style at palm pay for example,
and also in Rome that they created temples,
uh,
out with,
with columns and a superstructures that were made out of Tufa or,
or travertine.
And then they stuck oh,
those over white to make them look like marble even though they were not marble.
Uh,
but that they just didn't have access to marble readily enough to transform to
actually make these buildings out of marble itself.
There are,
there was some,
some flirtation with it.
They did import a certain amount of Greek marble to use,
uh,
for some buildings,
but it wasn't available at a low enough cost to allow the kind of full scale
marble building,
uh,
that they wanted to do.
What happens in the end of the reign of the reign of Caesar and into,
or the dictatorship of Caesar and in to the emperorship of Augustus,
is that all of a sudden a high quality,
relatively inexpensive marble becomes available.
Because what happens is the Romans begin to exploit in the lights is Arion
period and into the age of Augustus,
the marble quarries at Luna on the northwest coast of Italy.
Uh,
this is the same town as modern Carrara,
the same quarries that were used centuries later by none other than Michael
Angelo himself,
Carrara marble.
You all know Carrara marble called Luna,
this site called Luna in ancient Roman Times.
So Luna or Carrara Marble,
I show you a view here of the marble quarries are one of the marble quarries at
Luna.
Slash.
Carrara.
What it looks like today,
this is a reenactment of bringing the marble blocks down from the mountain,
uh,
for use in construction.
They basically do it the same way.
Today's,
they probably did it in ancient Roman times,
uh,
and it was fairly easy to get this and it was on the coast.
It was fairly easy to load this marble into boat,
bring it down to Australia,
and then up the Tiber to Rome.
And that began to be done,
uh,
in,
in with great success,
especially in the age of Augustus.
Going to Carrara today is a pleasure.
It's an interesting place to visit,
especially if you go there at the time of the,
um,
of the,
uh,
the marble exhibition that they have in the competition that they have a where
people,
uh,
make,
whatever out of out of Carrara marble and compete for prizes.
And I show you a view,
a taken during one of these,
one of these contests,
a here now on the screen.
And there are some amazing,
amazing works of art we might call them that come out of these competitions.
Here's one of my favorites you see over here,
uh,
the Mar,
the Luna Marble version of a,
an Italian Chink would change though these chink would chain toes,
which are,
were minuscule,
uh,
are not,
um,
not many of them exist today,
although you do see some antique versions here and there.
But I had one of these ones.
And you can see a picture of me in fact here in front of American Express and
not far from the Spanish steps.
The Piatsa d spun yet with my chink with Jane Doe is a long time ago.
Uh,
but you can see how small it is.
I'm actually standing on the front,
uh,
front,
passenger side,
uh,
popping up through the sunroof,
but use my size there and I'm about five,
seven compared to the car.
It gives you some sense of how small these cars were today.
So the Italians had been very good about,
about this sort of thing for some time and continue as you well know,
to drive for the most part small cars,
uh,
through the city.
And another one of my favorite,
uh,
entries into the competition or these Luna marble decapitated heads of one and a
Vieta Parone,
uh,
that were put forward in one of these competitions some years ago
with regard to transforming roam into a marble city.
Now that Carrara marble was available at a fairly low cost compared to the
importation of Greek marbles,
a Augustus begins to build his marble city.
And I'm going to show you two major commissions,
uh,
of Augustus today.
Uh,
the first of these is the forum of Augustus in Rome.
A forum,
uh,
or the forum are Gostem in Rome,
that that was,
uh,
very much in Augustus,
his mind from the beginning of his rise to power.
In fact,
there it's Sue Atonia is who tells us that the reason that Augustus built a
forum in Rome was because even though there were already two forums in Rome that
includes the Roman Forum and the Forum of Julius Caesar,
even though those two existed,
and we're both being used,
that the populations who attained,
Tony tells us the population was growing by leaps and bounds as were the need to
try judicial cases.
And that the play,
the spaces in the forums of the Roman Forum and in the Forum of Julius Caesar
did not allow for the needs of the populous or for these,
the needs of these judicial cases and that they needed to build another forum.
Well,
that's a good story,
but the likelihood is it had pretty much nothing to do with that.
I may have had something to do with that,
but not a lot to do with that.
Uh,
because,
uh,
Augustus had ulterior motives.
Augustus.
It was at the battle of Philippi,
that battle of 42 BC when Marc Antony and Octavian joined forces to defeat the
assassins of Julius Caesar.
It was right before that battle that Augustus vowed that if he won,
if he were successful,
uh,
that he would build a temple to Mars,
the Avenger Mars alter ulto,
our Mars Mars,
the Avenger in gratitude for helping him avenge the death of Julius Caesar,
the murder of Julius Caesar,
the assassination of Julius Caesar.
And so when he was successful,
he said,
I will build a,
that temple and that temple needed and environment.
Uh,
and uh,
as we've seen,
Romans often build temples inside complexes,
whether it was sanctuaries or forums.
Uh,
and so he had a good excuse to build a major forum in Rome as a domicile for the
temple of Mars old tour.
He didn't get around to it for a while.
Again the battle of Phillip Pie 42 but he had a lot of other things to contend
with,
namely Marc Antony and Cleopatra.
It wasn't until after the battle of Actium when he got rid of the two of them,
uh,
that he had time to build this temple to Marzel tour.
And we see it beginning to go up in 28 BC,
so considerably later than the original battle 28 BC.
And it was dedicated in Rome and a very important on a very important date,
the date of a,
of a d of two BC,
excuse me,
of two BC.
So,
uh,
begun in 28 BC and dedicated in to BC.
And that's the date that I've given you on the monument list,
the dedication of the temple of Marzel tour and the forum of Augustus in two BC.
We see it's planned here.
We will see momentarily that it was built in very close approximation and in
fact right next to the forum of Julius Caesar,
why?
Because of course,
Augustus wanted to associate himself with his divine adoptive father,
Caesar.
So he puts his own forum right next to Caesars.
We see the forum of Augustus here,
we can see that it follows in the main,
the plan of the forum of Julius Caesar.
It is a rectangular space open to the sky with colonnades on either side with a
temple in the center pushed up against the back wall and dominating the space in
front of it.
The only change here is the addition of these hemi cycles,
one on either side looking very much like the Hemi cycles that we looked at from
the sanctuary of Fortuna Prima Jania at Palestrina.
These embracing arms that serve to accentuate architecturally and visually the
temple in the center.
Uh,
and that also served as a place.
There are niches on either side where they could put statuary and the like seen
through the columns.
As you can see here,
the temple of Marzel tore itself again,
very similar to temples,
early Roman temples that we've been talking about.
Uh,
using the Etruscan plan,
the sod orientation,
single staircase,
deep porch,
freestanding columns in that porch.
Freestanding columns on either side,
but yet like an a trust in temple,
a flat back wall.
As you can see here,
some columns inside decorating the seller of the temple and then a single niche,
uh,
for the cult statue.
Uh,
inside and note here also the base,
I'll say something about the statute that said,
stood on that base later.
Here's a Google earth view of this part of Rome showing the connection between
this is,
you can see here the a forum of Julius Caesar.
As it looks today.
This is the entrance.
We're moving back toward the Capitoline hill.
These are those three columns that I showed you before are still preserved as
well as the columns of the colonnade on the left side that entered into the
shops.
Here's the modern via day Fori am periodically,
uh,
built by Mussolini.
What miss miscellany did was slice,
uh,
the Roman Forum and Julian Forum from the so called imperial fora to which they
were originally attached.
And any of you who've been in Rome recently know that this entire area as being
excavated,
the plan is event street is still there now,
but the plan is eventually we'll see whether this really happens because it's a
good be a traffic nightmare.
But the plan is to take that,
that uh,
muscle any street down eventually and reunite all of these forums in some great
archeological park.
Uh,
someday it would be exciting if that were to happen.
So the modern street,
but initially the forum of Caesar would have stood exactly next to the form of
Augustus.
We see that here and if you look carefully,
you can see the remains of the temple of Marzel tour as well as a precinct wall
that is preserved.
It was 115 foot precinct wall protecting the forum from just the area we were
talking about before,
that question about,
uh,
housing for the well to do and the less well to do in ancient Rome.
Protecting the forum from the so called Sabura sub.
You are a,
which was that area of Rome in which all of those rickety wooden tenement houses
were located in which we're constantly going up in fires to protect the temple
cause marble can burn to protect the temple of Marzel two or from all of that
stuff.
Uh,
that was back there in the Seborga.
Here's another view from Google Earth from taken from the other side,
showing the remains of the temple of Marzel tore pushed up against the back
wall.
And then that precinct wall that is very well preserved,
snaking its way around dividing the forum proper,
the sacred space from the residential area called the [inaudible] that was
behind.
Here's a view of the,
uh,
of the,
precinct wall as it looks from the outside of the forum today are,
there are some additions that were made in later times,
you know,
medieval looking windows and the like.
Uh,
but for the most part it's preserved as it was.
You can see we're dealing with ashler blocks made out of pepper,
Reno stone,
pep,
We've talked about pepper reno before.
It's a form of Tufa,
a stone that was used here with Ashleigh blocks for uh,
the and circling precinct wall.
You can see the coloration of those,
uh,
pepper,
Reno blocks,
grayish brownish color here.
Uh,
and you can see the difference between that and the temple,
the remains of the temple,
the columns,
the steps of the temple as well as some other decoration.
And also some of the walls were made out of Luna or Carrara Marble Luna or
Carrara marble for this temple.
This is a view of the temple of Marzel tour as it looks today.
It's in ruinous state,
but enough is preserved for us to get a very good sense of what it originally
looked like.
You can see that the podium is tall.
You can see that it's made out of Tufa.
Uh,
you can see that the steps are sheathed in Carrara marble,
uh,
brought from,
those quarries that we discussed before.
You can see that the columns were also made out of solid Carrara marble.
We see that here we see a wall in Carrara marble and we see the distinction
between that and the pep reno walls.
Uh,
you can also see in this very good view,
a,
uh,
one of the Hemi cycles on the left hand side.
And you can see those niches that I mentioned before or that would have held
statuary that you could see through the columns.
This is a restored view in the Ward Perkins,
a textbook which,
uh,
shows you what the temple would have looked like in antiquity and when it was in
its final form.
And you can see the,
the everything we've described,
the tall podium,
single staircase facade orientation.
You can see also that there was sculpture in the pediment.
And we know something about that.
Uh,
you can see the columns on either side and you can see in the second story and
you can barely make them out.
But take my word,
those are instead of columns,
they are figures of women,
uh,
that we're going to say something about.
Uh,
and you can see those again on both sides.
So this gives you a sense of what the temple would've looked like in its hay
day.
The favored,
uh,
Capitol column type and Capitol of the Romans.
The Corinthian is what is used here.
Uh,
you can see a restore,
a,
a preserved capital.
And how beautifully rendered they were.
A very high quality capital's done out of Luna or Carrara marble.
Uh,
we can see the characteristic triple row of a canvas leaves the spiral volume.
It's growing out of those,
the central flower that we see always in the Corinthian order,
uh,
for,
the columns that were used for the temple and for most of the side columns on
the first story as well.
But in some cases,
those columns were replaced with others that have,
instead of the spiral volume,
it's growing out of the account.
This leaves Pega Psi.
We need horses.
And I show you a detail of one of those pegs cy here,
uh,
to have a capital with an animal that replacing the spirals,
is called a zone amorphic capitol Zhou [inaudible] Zoomorphic,
z.
O.
O m.
O r p.
H.
I.
C.
So a morphic capital.
Uh,
and it's interesting to note that we see similar zoomorphic capitals in Greece a
a bit earlier than this structure at a gateway that I'm going to show you at a
place called hallucis.
We'll return to this when we discuss a Roman Greece later in this semester.
Uh,
and these have,
instead of Pega side,
these have bull proteomes,
the tops of bulls emanating out of the canvas leads.
But I show it to you to make one point.
And that is that it seems very likely that there was some interesting
architectural exchange ideas,
architects,
and so on going on between Athens and Rome,
uh,
in the late Republican period in the time of Julius Caesar and into the age of
Augustus.
And it's an issue that we'll return to in the future.
We're going to see that Augustus not only builds his marbles city in order to
make it look like,
you know,
more like grease,
more like Athens,
uh,
and to connect his new golden age with the golden age of Pericles and Athens.
Uh,
but we see,
we see very specific,
uh,
Greek models being used.
For example,
one of these is a freeze from the forum of Augustus.
The other is a freeze from one of the three temples on the Acropolis in Athens
of the fifth century B BC,
the so called Eric theone or Eric theum and the Latin eyes version a.
And one of these is from one and one of these is from the other.
And I just wondered quickly if any of you want to guess,
which is the Roman one and which is the Greek one that had copies.
You can see this alternation of the Lotus and Paul met leaves here and he,
quick thoughts.
How many of you think this is the Greek one?
Okay,
this is the Roman one.
This is the Roman one at the top.
This is the Greek one down here.
The Greek one down here,
or more deeply undercut,
which is I think what throws people,
uh,
the Roman one from the forum of Augustus up above.
But the important point for us,
again,
uh,
that they are looking back at Greek buildings of the fifth century and they are
copying what they see.
Uh,
we see here a model of the forum of Augustus with the Temple of Maura's old tour
inside that forum with the,
uh,
embracing x,
Z,
z dry or heavy cycles on either side.
Or you can see that the exterior of the structure was quite plain.
I just,
in the way that a Domus Etol lick us outside was playing.
And it was only when you got inside,
I bet you got a real sense of,
uh,
of the,
um,
the glory of the architecture.
So I think you can see well here and most interesting for us.
I mentioned that,
uh,
these columns and the temple were Corinthian.
The columns on the first story over here,
we're Corinthian.
But in the second story on the left and right sides of the forum,
the columns are replaced by figures of women,
by figures of maidens.
And I show you two of them are survived.
There's two of them are well preserved.
I show them to you here,
these figures of maidens that replace the columns that support the capital's on
top of their heads.
Uh,
and they flank,
uh,
this shield in the center with the depiction of a male head.
This is the God Jupiter,
a certain,
a certain guys of the God,
Jupiter,
Amazon.
As you can see him here and we have,
we have information that tells us that Alexander the great used to play shields
in the,
uh,
in,
in the,
in the Parthenon,
in Athens and elsewhere after great military victories.
And it is possible that that sort of thing is being referred to here because we
know Augusta's like Pompey before him a had a thing that for Alexander and like
to associate himself with Alexander,
but most important for us is the fact that these maidens have clear precedence
in the Greek world.
The famous porch of the maidens on the Athenian Acropolis fifth century BC,
the Eric theone again,
n and the,
the Greek version,
the Eric theone of Athens fifth century BC,
same set of maidens.
We know that these had fallen into disrepair and the age of Augustus Augustus
visited Athens three times.
He did not like seeing these in disrepair.
And in fact,
he had his own architects replace one of them with a Roman copy.
And while they were doing that,
they made plaster casts of these maidens.
They brought those plaster cast back to Rome.
And then in reduced scale,
they duplicated them for the,
uh,
for the,
forum of Augustus in Rome.
So appropriations from Greece,
appropriations in part because Augustus liked them.
Uh,
but also I don't think there's any question that he was trying to draw a
relationship between himself,
his new golden age and the golden age of Pericles and Athens.
We also have evidence for what the pediment,
the sculpture in the pediment looked like.
And I want to turn to that now.
This is a relief that dates to a slightly later period that purports to
represent the pediment of the temple of Mars old tour.
Uh,
and I show it to you here and we can tell from this exactly what these
sculptural display was all about.
Uh,
in the pediment of this temple we see here in the center,
not surprisingly,
Mars old tour himself.
Marzel tour depicted with a bare chest,
uh,
next to him,
to his left,
to his right.
Excuse me.
To our left,
we see a figure of a woman.
This is Venus and Venus,
as you can see,
has a something on her left shoulder.
It is a cupid,
uh,
so Venus with Cupid,
Venus,
the consort of Mars,
and then over here a personification that we believe depicts for tuna for two.
Now the goddess of fortune who brought fortune to Augustus in his battle.
And then over here,
uh,
a seated figure of Roma with her arms and armor.
Keep this figure in your mind because I'm going to show you another seat in Roma
and very soon.
And then over here,
a reclining figure of the Tiber River,
the Tiber on the liver,
on which Rome was built over here,
a seated figure we believe is Romulus,
the founder of Rome on the Palatine Hill and overhear a reclining
personification of the Palatine.
So most important that the building honored of course Marzel tour and that Mars
old tour was depicted in the pediment.
There was also a cult statue inside the temple of Mars a.
And we believe we know what that looked like as well because we believe we have
a copy of it in a relief from Algiers of that is still preserved.
That depicts Mars in the center of this Marzel tour.
Again,
this time the warlike Marzel tour because you can see he's wearing his
breastplate and his helmet,
his consort Venus is once again by his side.
Venus is leaning on a pedestal.
She's very seductive.
Her,
her drapery is falling off her shoulder as you can see.
And she looks toward Mars and then cupid down here offering her a sword in a
sheath,
probably Mars,
his own a sword.
And then over here a figure that's very controversial.
I youthful looking figure with a bare chest,
uh,
and you can see a full cap of hair.
Uh,
and we think that he is actually the divinized Julius Caesar,
very botox compared to what he's rejuvenated compared to what he looked like.
A in that green diabase portrait that I showed you before,
uh,
a very youthful,
a divine Caesar,
which shows you what happens to people in Roman times when they were a
divinized.
They were able to shed a fair number of years and were depicted in much younger
versions in there divinized state.
So this probably a reflection as you can see,
the figures stand on bases and figures that stand on bases and Roman relief
sculpture are usually meant to be statues.
And we believe that this is again,
a rendition of what the triple a set of statutes would have looked like inside
the temple to return to the plan quickly.
Just to make the point that the sculptural program,
we're concerned here primarily with architecture,
but the sculptural program,
uh,
was very complicated but very interesting.
And the figures were very carefully aligned with one another to get the message
across.
So as you looked at the temple,
you would've seen Marzel tour in the center of the pediment.
If you were allowed to walk in to the temple,
which usually only the priests could do,
you would see the cult statue with Marzel tour in the center there,
there was an equestrian statue that was put up of Augustus in to BC when he was
given the title pot tear poetry I the father of his country.
And then all along the colonnades,
there would have been statuary,
including an image of,
uh,
of um,
Nissan,
this side Romulus on this side and the so called Sumi weary,
the great men of Rome,
both Augustus's colleagues and also his rivals in their portraits on either
side,
a kind of giant picture gallery.
I enjoy and portrait gallery of,
uh,
of the,
of,
of Rome,
of the great men of Rome,
of the greatest men of Rome,
namely Augustus himself.
Uh,
and uh,
his,
uh,
his ancestry,
both divine and mythological,
Avaya and nice,
and also Venus.
The second marble building that I want to show you today is the famous altar of
Augustan peace.
The ARRA pacas goosed die.
Uh,
which is one of,
if not my most favorite building in monument in Rome.
And one that I've had a personal obsession with my entire scholarly life.
I've written a lot on this monument and have a lot of thoughts which have
changed significantly over the years about this very important structure we know
about it.
Augustus tells us about the altar of Augustan peace himself in his raise guest
die.
He tells us on his return,
and I'm quoting Augustus here from RG on his return to Rome from Spain and gall.
He had gone to Spain and gold,
which were the western part of the empire in order to make some diplomatic
treaties on my return to Rome from Spain and goal.
After successfully restoring law and order to the provinces,
the Senate decided,
and this happened in 13 BC to consecrate the Arra Pacas Al Goose die on the
campus.
Marshus the so called field of Mars and area of Rome in honor of my return at
which officials,
priests,
and vestal virgins should offer an annual sacrifice.
We believe that the monument being referred to here is the one that you see now
before you,
the Arra Pahlka sal goose dye made entirely of Luna or Carrara marble solid Luna
or Carrara marble,
and even more of a marble building in a sense than the Temple and forum that
we've looked at thus far.
Uh,
it is a marble building that we believe that we know,
we know it's dates,
quite specifically.
We know that it was a consecrated on the 4th of July and easy date to remember
for all of us.
The 4th of July in 13 BC was when it was consecrated and it was completed and
dedicated on the 30th of January in nine VC,
the 30th of January just happened to be the birthday of Augustus.
His wife Livia,
no coincidence there.
She was obviously lobbying,
uh,
for that.
Uh,
so on her birthday,
30th of January in nine BC,
this structure is dedicated.
We,
we know that,
uh,
it,
we,
there's a lot of controversy as to exactly what event is referred to on this
monument because we'll see that there was a procession that refers to some
historical event.
Uh,
we will also see that the monument is covered with all kinds of sculptural
decoration,
including flowering a campus plants,
including mythological and legendary scenes,
including historical scenes and trying to decipher the web of all these and
their relationship to one another is fairly complex.
Uh,
what's important to us as we look at this,
um,
is,
and I want to show you here from Ward Perkins a plan and an accident metric
view,
which will give us a very good sense of what this altar was all about.
Uh,
we can see that the altar proper was located in the center of the structure.
It's a kind of u shaped alter,
which goes what goes back to Greek precedents.
The most famous use shaped alts alter of the Hellenistic period.
Some of you may know at the altar of Zeus at Pergamon,
the great altar of Zeus at Pergamon,
which you see in the upper most part now in Berlin,
but these u shaped altars were used in Greece and you can see that same you
shaped form here,
use for the altar,
the altar proper,
where the sacrifice was actually made is located inside this precinct,
which is open to the sky and most importantly has double doors.
A doorway on the eastern side of the monument and a doorway on the western side
of the the monument.
Even though there are two doors,
you note that there is only a single staircase on the western side.
So the Romans,
despite the fact that they've given it a dual focus by putting two doors,
they still give it a single focus by a single staircase.
So it's the facade ism of Roman architecture reigned supreme.
As you can see here,
the fact that there were double doorways,
very significant and we try to,
we've tried to sort out why that might be.
There are two possible precedents are two possible references that are being
made here.
One,
two a Greek alter,
a a Greek fifth century BC alter,
which shouldn't surprise us since we've seen that Augustus is looking back at
the fifth century BC and Greece and mining it for architectural ideas and
associations.
We see here what is the,
uh,
it was a,
is a restored view of the altar of the 12 gods or the altar of pity that was
located in the Greek market place,
the Athenian in Athens,
the Athenian Agora,
the marketplace and Athens fifth century BC.
You can see that it consisted of an altar in the center with a precinct wall
with double doorways,
one on either side here and with relief sculpture.
So it looks like that might well be an important model again and not
surprisingly since it dates to the fifth century but also important.
And I show you an image of it on a Roman coin.
Here is the so called shrine of Janus,
the two headed God,
j a n u s the shrine of Janus,
which we know is located in the Roman forum.
And tradition had it that when the doors,
because it had double doors,
what had two sides,
cause he was a two headed God.
So two sides,
both with doors,
both with double doors and that when those double doors were closed,
it's signaled that peace reigned throughout the empire.
And we know in the Res Guest Die,
Augustus tells us that he closed the doors of the shrine of Janus.
He brags three times during his reign.
So it is very likely that the double doors on the shrine of Janus are referred
to not surprisingly in an altar that was put up two piece to the piece that
Augustus brought to Rome through his various military victories and also through
his diplomatic conquests,
his diplomatic treaties like the one that he assigned in,
uh,
Spain and gall.
I want to take you quickly through the monument and keep in mind always that
it's made out of Luna or Carrara marble to show you some of the,
this is not of course in sculpture.
So I'm not going to go into the sculpture in any detail,
but I want you to be aware of it,
uh,
because some of the motifs are important in our understanding also of
architecture.
We see here two views of the altar.
You see these winged Lion Griffin's that are very popular motifs in the Augustan
period as well as the spiral and the cannabis plant that was also popular and
Augustan Times a figural freeze that represents the vestal virgins that were
referred to as those who are,
who,
um,
to which offerings are,
are,
you know,
the sacrifice is taking place in part in honor of them.
Uh,
but we see here I sacrifice itself where the animal victims are being brought in
for slaughter.
We also see,
if we look at right where we're now inside the monument,
we've looked at the altar proper.
If we look at the precinct wall,
the inside of the precinct wall,
we see that as very well preserved.
And we see it is zoned to s two,
essentially two zones with slats all done in Carrara Marble slats down below,
uh,
that looked like either a wooden wall or perhaps a fence of some sort.
Then above also depicted in Carrara marble.
These great garland did swags,
uh,
that you see hanging from pilasters,
but also from the skulls of bulls.
I'll show you a detail in a moment when you'll see those skulls better,
the skulls of the bowls that have been sacrificed on this altar.
And then above the swags,
uh,
you can see these libation dishes.
Uh,
and what has been speculated,
and I think it's ingenious on the part of the scholars who first came up with
this,
that what they think is being represented here is actually a copy or a rendition
of the wooden,
the,
uh,
the temporary wouldn't alter that would have stood on this site,
because remember,
they're consecrating it already in 13 BC,
but the structure itself isn't built until nine,
and they have to keep offering this annual sacrifice so they have to offer it
somewhere.
So the suggestion is they made a makeshift wooden altar that looked like this
with actual wooden slats,
wouldn't poles,
a real garlands and so on.
Uh,
and that what they've done on the altar is to create a rendition of that on the
interior,
uh,
interior precinct wall of the Arra pacas a detail of these garlands here you can
see the bolts,
skulls or boot cranium extremely well and I thought you'd be interested to see
and perhaps not surprised that we can see very close renditions of this.
Also in painting of the time this painting on the left comes from the house of
Livia in Rome.
We didn't look at it,
we looked at the villa of Livia Prima Porta and we looked at Augustus,
his house.
But when we did that,
I told you Olivia had her own house across the street from Augustus is and this
painting is from that.
It's clearly a second style wall residual first style done in paint,
projecting columns.
Garland's hanging from those columns,
garlands,
interlace with ribbons.
Just as you see here.
And when this was painted,
which it was in antiquity,
it would have looked very similar to what you see on the other side of the
screen.
So interesting interrelationships between decoration in sculpture and
architecture and decoration in paint.
The accident metric view again shows you,
here's that inner precinct that we've just described,
that the outside had a series of panels,
square panels,
uh,
four of them on the short sides and then are on the front sides with the doors
are flanking the doors.
And then on the other sides of the north and south of freeze.
And I show you a detail of that freeze,
a freeze,
the subject matter of which is somewhat controversial.
I'm not going to go into that here today.
Suffice it to say though,
that Augustus senators,
magistrates,
members of the priesthood,
members of the imperial family all take part in these processions that are
located on the north and south.
Those processions rest on these,
a campus plants down below,
which when you think a bit,
think of it has absolutely nothing to do with reality because how could a
procession of human figures be supported,
uh,
by,
canvas plants below impossible.
And yet it is,
you know,
some of that fantasy thinking that we saw in third style Roman painting.
And I show you,
I remind you of a detail of garden room queue over here where we saw some of
that fanciful third style painting,
uh,
seems to come into play here.
In fact,
the,
the delicate of canvas leads absolutely beautifully rendered in the are podcast.
You seeing the same sort of thing in the black background of the,
uh,
of the,
garden room Q.
So again,
interesting in correspondences between painting and architectural decoration.
The freeze on the south side has a portrait of Augustus himself.
You can see him here veiled,
uh,
taking part in this procession as well as members of the imperial family,
including children.
Here's a little boy in a toga and here's a little boy who is very controversial
in a,
um,
some kind of a foreign costume.
And I mentioned that I've written a lot on this.
And in my most recent article on this subject,
I talk in particular about these,
this,
these children and foreign dress as possibly children who were uh,
the,
the what we call,
um,
pledges of empire or hostage guests that belonged,
that were children of very important rulers of other parts of the world who were
brought to Rome to live with the emperor in his house in the palace to be
trained with the objective of eventually sending them back to their native lands
to serve as rulers.
It was,
Augustus is way of creating a kind of hedge demonic empire that he controlled by
getting all of these people on his side and then placing those friends of Rome
into important positions around the world.
And I think that's referred to in these scenes.
Again,
I'm not going to go in any detail into the mythological scenes,
but they are scenes like a Roma seated on a pile of arms.
And Armor,
just as we saw her in the pediment of the temple of Marzel tour and hear a scene
that seems to have shown Mars,
uh,
overseeing Romulus and Remus being suckled by the she will.
So references to Rome's historic and also legendary and mythological past,
uh,
clearly,
in this monument,
perhaps most interesting to all of us from the point of view of architecture is
the original location of this monument in relationship to Augustus,
his tomb.
And also what has been happening there in recent years under the direction of
the famous American architect Richard Meier.
I show you a view from Google earth and aerial view showing,
uh,
the mausoleum of Augustus,
this large round tomb that we will look at on Thursday,
showing a Piatsa,
uh,
around it and showing from the air the Richard Meyer Museum that has been built
to enclose the Arra pockets.
This was not the right near the Tiber river.
This was not the original location of the [inaudible],
which was up over here.
It ended up beneath a Po,
a palace in the renaissance period.
And at that time,
some pieces of it were,
uh,
were,
were taken apart and made their way to,
to,
to museums in Rome but also to museums as far away as Paris.
And it is actually to muscle Leni that we can be grateful for.
Bringing all of those pieces back together and reconstructing the ARRA POC is,
couldn't reconstruct it cause that palace is still there now,
but reconstructing it right on the Tiber river next to the mausoleum of
Augustus.
And then having this whole Piatsa redesigned as the Piatsa honoring Augustus,
the Piatsa Piatsa,
a imperatore honoring Augustus,
but also honoring with Salini because there's a major inscription to miscellany
as well as buildings,
very much in the so called fascist style.
Uh,
we see the Meyer building again here and I show you,
uh,
the,
um,
the travertine cause Myra was careful to use at least some travertine in this
structure.
The travertine base,
although this was not as,
this actually belongs to an original precinct that was located before,
that was done by Mussolini's architect with the entire text of the rays,
guests die.
Fortunately,
my kept that and an s and kept that wall as part of his own building.
Here you see one of the fascist structures in the area of built by my selenium
and then the famous Alfredo Ristorante.
I'm not actually recommending it,
but it's well known there better restaurants to eat in Rome,
but because it has a certain historical cache at any rate I just mentioned to
you that it's there.
This is the interesting inscription that makes reference to Miss Illini.
And note the flying victory figure,
which we'll see decorates often Roman arches carrying this bundle of twigs and
rods at the Romans that Roman,
the Roman bodyguards of the emperor used to carry the so called fos gaze.
If you ever wondered where the word fascism comes from,
it comes from the Roman fos gaze Mussolini's name.
You can see part of it here and new s s o l part of it scratched out after his
death.
Uh,
and uh,
discredit a door,
you know,
in the,
in,
in the 30s.
And then ultimately what's been interesting to me is I've watched this
inscription and photographed it year after year whenever I'm there.
I've noticed recently that he's having is something of a revival because they
are,
and he ha he is with selenium,
is having something over a Bible in Italy and um,
there's a good deal of interest in him.
And they have filled his name part of when they redid the museum,
they also refilled in his name.
As you can see here.
I just wanted to make a point about the sighting of the Arra pacas and its
relationship to the mausoleum of Augustus.
Remember,
it's no longer,
it's what its original locates now.
It's over here,
right next to the mausoleum and the Tiber that was not its original location.
It was located over here along the ancient via Flaminia,
the street that Augustus talk when he returned from Spain and gall,
it was put up right here.
Uh,
and,
uh,
it had in front of it an obelisk that was brought from Egypt and that obelisk
was part of a Sundial,
uh,
that would,
that was orchestrated carefully enough so that the shadow from the sun would
fall exactly on the center of the Arra pockets on Augustus is birthday.
That's how carefully orchestrated it was.
And the fact that,
uh,
there is an Egyptian obelisk and there's mention in the inscription on that
obelisk of the victory over Cleopatra and Antony at the battle of Actium and
that the are pockets commemorates his diplomatic treaties in the western part of
the empire in France.
And Spain seems to me to be,
uh,
a reference to the fact that Augustus was victorious in all parts of the Roman
Empire,
the Western,
as well as the eastern part of the empire referenced here.
And then close proximity to the mausoleum of Augustus.
Cause we've already talked about the fact that in the minds of the Romans
victory in battle and victory over death,
we're essentially synonymous.
Both of them referred to here.
I'm not implying that this was planned as a complex.
The Mazal Liam is,
we'll see on Thursday dates to 28 to 23.
It was built much earlier than the altar of 13 to nine.
But I think when they decided to add the Arra pockets to this complex,
there was a great deal of thought that was given to siting it in relationship to
the tomb and to thinking about the whole,
uh,
as a complex,
at least at that particular juncture.
And I show you two more restored views where you can see the obelisk and the way
in which it cast.
It served as a Sundial,
cast,
a shadow toward the [inaudible] pockets.
And then there,
even though this is a little bit out of focus,
the relationship of the very large tomb to the obelisk and ultimately to the
Aarp Ahca.
So a,
an area that was not planned as a complex but grew into one,
uh,
a,
an image of MOUs.
Selenia wonderful photograph of muscle Leni visiting the Arra pockets after it
was restored and dedicated and placed in,
uh,
a,
a complex design by his architect.
And then an image here of Richard Meyer,
a celebrating,
uh,
the,
the rest of the cleaning and a placement of the,
our APOC is inside the new museum designed by him.
And in just a few minutes,
I'd like to run through a series of slides because I think a particularly
interesting issue for all of us in one that I hope that we will debate in the
online forum is the fact that the building by Richard Meyer,
this museum which has been praised and maligned,
both,
uh,
this museum is the first modern building that has been put up in the center,
the central core of Rome since the time of muscly knee.
Since muscle Leni redesigned the Piatsa Boosto imperatore and added some other
buildings,
uh,
to the landscape of Rome.
There are other,
there are,
there are buildings by major architects,
including Meyer himself.
Mayor built a jubilees church a few years,
a number of years ago.
Uh,
and Renzo Piano and other architects have been working in Rome,
but they are not,
their buildings are located on the outskirts and the sort of suburbs of the city
and not in the city itself.
This is the only new building that has been added to the city.
And you can see from this particular view why some people think of it as a kind
of white elephant that really doesn't fit the tenor of uh,
the um,
the,
uh,
the city.
And in fact,
when it first opened in 2006,
uh,
and I was there not long after and uh,
taking some photographs of some pictures of the building that were outside that
had been,
the graffiti had been added to a,
and they're,
you know,
they call it the Meyer criminology.
And over here,
this is my favorite.
It says [inaudible] far meaning those architects of the past where a lot better,
uh,
than Meijer is the,
is the message here.
So there are,
there are many people who do not like this building and I think a case can be
made with regard to the outside.
My are,
there is a nod,
you know,
to ancient Rome with the travertine wall that is outside and continues inside.
But it's typical Meyer white glass and,
and a lot of people,
I mean I don't mind that sort of thing,
but a lot of people feel that it doesn't,
it doesn't really suit the environment with the two baroque churches right
across the way and so on and so forth.
So I think a case can be made for the exterior,
but when you enter into the museum and got pay your fee and then go into the
door and into the,
our pacas itself,
I have to say and pass the marble,
the plaster casts of Augustus in his family,
uh,
that you can see lined up against the travertine wall.
When you confront the building itself in its new interior,
I have to say,
I,
I'm very impressed and very moved by this interior.
You've got the sort of egg crates,
ceiling and these wonderful louvered windows that allow you to see not only
miscellaneous fascists buildings next door,
but also the mausoleum of Augustus.
Uh,
that it,
that it really,
I'm not,
the light is superb and it really does give you a chance to see this altar in a
way that it hasn't been seen before.
And especially at night.
I enjoy seeing it at night because as you go by it,
they have it laid it up as you drive by.
One of the greatest things to do in Rome,
by the way,
is late at night when all the traffic has died down either by car vesper or
whatever.
I just,
just get around the city,
go from one part of the city to another,
which you can zip around late at night and driving along lingo.
Tevere the street along the Tiber river and seeing the Ma,
the alter of the are Apaka Pakistan who started light it up inside the new Myer
Museum,
like a jewel and a jewel box.
I can't help but think Augustus is smiling,
uh,
somewhere,
to think that everything he did to try to preserve his memory for posterity has
been done and has been helped to a great extent by the great American architect
Richard Meyer.
Thank you.